[Music]
have you ever wondered how secure your
private messages actually are like can
hackers
big tech or the government
read what you're sending they quite
possibly could be depending on what app
you're using and what type of encryption
they have baked into them so let's talk
about how encryption works and why you
would even want your digital
communications encrypted anyway
so what is end-to-end encryption well
it's basically technology that ensures
that the only people able to see the
message you're sending is you and the
receiver nobody in between can
understand what you said and here's how
it works when you send a message hey
what's your address your phone's chat
app turns it into gibberish and then
around it then passes through servers on
the way to the recipient but remains
illegible
eventually it reaches the receiving
person's chat app which has the unique
key to decipher the code
and then hud are on hey what's your
address using encryption matters because
we send some of our most private details
through messaging apps family photos
phone numbers maybe even passwords when
your messages are sealed from one end to
the other it prevents them from being
seen by middlemen who might be trying to
target you with personalized ads or even
worse like they could be trying to
violate your privacy so how do you know
when your messages are encrypted let's
start with apps that are often
pre-installed on your phone
for iphone users if you use apple's
messages app to send an imessage and the
text bubble appears blue that's apple's
way of telling you it's secured from end
to end
if you text someone and your message
shows up green it's an sms message and
there's no way to encrypt it
mobile carriers can see sms messages
google messages has a relatively new
encryption option you'll know your
android messages are encrypted if you
see this lock icon
if you don't make sure your chat
features are turned on in your settings
and make sure you're both using the
latest version of the messages app
now let's talk about some of the free
apps you might have downloaded
there's an app called signal and your
personal account is tied to your phone
number and your device it's considered
one of the most secure services you can
use for encrypted messaging but beware
if you forget your phone password which
may be unlikely or you simply can't get
into your phone for one reason or
another you're out of luck those
messages are gone then there's whatsapp
which is owned by facebook parent meta
it says it uses signals encryption
technology to keep both itself and
snoopers out of your messages both
signal and whatsapp have encryption
turned on by default
on the app telegram you have to turn on
secret chats for encryption
on instagram and facebook messenger
turning on vanish mode or tapping this
little lot icon before sending a message
we'll do this
internet privacy experts told me that if
you don't have these encryption features
toggled on there's little to nothing
stopping companies from using what you
send to target you with personalized
advertisements oh and some platforms are
not encrypted at all such as dm sent on
twitter twitter says it uses access to
your dms to scan for spam and abuse it
also recently settled a federal trade
commission lawsuit where officials
alleged twitter deceptively used users
phone numbers and email addresses for
targeted ads well so now you're
encrypted well you should know that
those encrypted messages are only as
secure as where you back them up so try
to make sure you're using a cloud
provider that encrypts things from end
to end if not you can backup your
messages to a computer or just know that
the cloud provider has the keys to
decrypt those messages now not everyone
is in favor of end-to-end encryption
some governing bodies want a way of
seeing what people are sending that way
they can more closely monitor for
criminal activity after a 2015 mass
shooting in san bernardino in california
the fbi asked apple to make software to
break into the shooter's phone but apple
refused any criminal investigation a
competent investigator would try and use
all lawful tools
to get access to that device there's
already a door on that iphone
essentially we're asking apple take the
vicious guard dog away let us try and
pick the lock apple says if it were to
weaken encryption it could create a
bigger security issue should hackers
figure out how they did it
it also said in this case that it
responded to investigators requests for
information within hours
it's a complicated issue that's way
bigger than any individual phone maker
if we got rid of encryption banking
information emails really anything we
want to send privately over the internet
could be at stake but from a security
perspective end-to-end encryption is the
most secure way right now to make sure
that only one person is seeing what
you're sending